تطورات الميدانيه مستمره في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا نتابعها اذا في ابرزها هذا اليوم
المزيد من التقدم الاوكراني جنوبا على
محور زابيولوجيا الجيش الاوكراني اعلن انه
حقق تقدما في نوفا بروكو بيفكا باتجاه
مدينه ميلي احدى المدن الثلاث الكبرى التي
تسعى القوات الاوكرانيه للسيطره عليها
جنوبا لقطع طريق الامداد بين القرم ومناطق
سيطره روسيا شرقا في مقابل تكثيف روسيا
غاراتها الجويه في المنطقه يعزو الجيش
الاوكراني هذا التقدم الى ان خط الدفاع
الروسيه الثاني اقل قوه من الخط الاول
الذي اخترقه الجيش الاوكراني حين سيطر على
روبوتينو في المحور نفسه قبل اسبوع
بالتزامن مع ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اليوم اسقاط طائره اوكرانيه مسيره
في شبه جزيره القرم
في الشرق تحدثت القوات المواليه لروسيا عن
سقوط قتلى وجرحى في قصر اوكراني على
مدينتي دونيتسك
وماكييفكا وفي روسيا قالت السلطات ان
انظمه الدفاع الجوي اسقطت ثلاث طائرات
مسيره في مناطق عده في محيط العاصمه موسكو
دون تسجيل اصابات او اضرار